hi reject nation it's that time again
that monday night football time
that time where a quarter of the
audience who watches a mandalorian
trailer during their football game goes
i'm a football fan not really here for
star wars and then the other quarter of
the audience goes
i've been waiting all day for this
mandalorian trailer and then the other
50 percent don't even watch the game and
just wait for it to come online
word of that representation today i
don't even know who's playing but i'm
excited to watch the mandalorian we'll
be covering the show
on youtube here hopefully we'll be able
to get all reactions public for the
mandalorian up here on this channel full
length reaction watch alarms will be at
our patreon
as per usual anywho let's watch this
trailer
[Applause]
oh cool
i'm here on business i need your help
i've been requested to bring this one
back to its kind
if i can locate other mandalorians they
can guide
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
wow the chase sequences look incredible
[Applause]
yes
oh look at that score picking up yes
that emmy-winning score
yeah man oh that was beautiful did you
guys catch us so katana
sabine wren ezra bridger's in the show
now oh no
oh my god boba fett did you catch him
did you catch them guys
dude that's the mandalorian who's going
to guide him through the show that they
showed too much in the stream
i think he's going to yeah i mean that
could be hinting at that
i mean it's probably gonna tie in in
some way
to the whole thing with bo katan of how
when she last had the dark saber
using it to unite the mandalores and
then now it's in the hands of
gideon so you know he's gotta encounter
more mandalores it's the mandalorian you
know it has a novel coming along
but what the trailer's been getting us
right now they're really enhancing the
chase sequences
that those look incredible the last
season i can't really think of ones
where i'm like there's moments
but in terms of you know star wars
vehicle chasing sequences
it looks so freaking cool we have the
cam uh
this freeze frame right now at around
the 41 second mark
is that the horatio sans methoral
character right here it looks like him
maybe he got
uncarbonited yeah or maybe it's just you
know one another one of those creatures
or whatever you've got to bring him back
right
yeah horatio sans is what the fans have
been demanding i mean he started in the
first episode of the show you got to
bring him back again
first episode every season horatio says
the tone the characters these little
tidbits i'm sure new rock stars is going
to have a field day breaking all this
down i mean you saw that weapon before
that people
in the last season with the iron man
looking kind of yeah
but it just is such a cool looking gag
and especially and
what i think is probably part of that
other scene that we've seen before where
baby yoda closes the
egg and everything like oh it definitely
is it's a cool uh capper on that this
one
kind of looks like part of jabba's
palace
yeah a little bit because even in the
boxing rings you see the gamorians
this is like an expansion of the first
trailer and the expansion of that little
teaser that came out last week
it's like these little tidbits of
expansions but you know that they're
doing this not because they don't have
anything to offer this season is that
they got so many goodies in store
and they're reserving them for the
actual experience of watching the show
well i gotta imagine that if any of
these studios is savvy about the very
fact that a hundred thousand people are
about to grab this trailer and
fine tooth combing for all the internet
video hours of detail
i think yeah they're probably playing
with us and that's clue us into a couple
characters are going to be really
important and that's all we need because
we know everyone's going to watch
there's even this really cool moment
where in the desert it looks like you
have this
like skeleton of a bantha in there yeah
i get the big horn
showing the ruins ooh man he's so cool
it's
the beauty of the scuzzier side of the
universe you know and it really feels
like that
grief cargo and car dune are going to be
a much bigger part of this season
especially
yeah i think they're going to take their
action to the next
level guys what'd you think of this
special look are you underwhelmed does
it just hype you up some more leave your
thoughts down below make sure to
subscribe and click that notification
bell keeping the lookout for when our
first mandalorian reaction is up that we
will be covering weekly
hit that like button last but not least
maria hammond let's face it out of all
the patronage
who is the one there that resembles all
three
of mando grief and cara dune
you're like cara doom where you're a
strong female woman you're like
mando because you are a caretaker you
look after your
loved ones and sometimes you gotta be a
little bit tough and you're like
grief with your witty remarks and your
blunt straightforward way of speaking
you are the embodiment of the three
leads
of the mandalorian and we are your baby
yodos
yeah just carry us around the galaxy
with you we're happy to come along all
your adventures
we're happy to you know intervene if you
should get in trouble you know
stick up for you when things get tough
love you maria
i hope you're being safe i hope things
get a little bit better for you on some
things that you were mentioning were
a little bit tough but right now i want
you to know that you are very near and
dear to our hearts
and protect the galaxy meet me for some
bone broth
you